it is so easy to win for everyone's like
struggling to win it's like most of the
pain that people experience is purely in
their own minds emotional burnout which
I think people mislabel as burnout when
really it's just like they don't know
how to reframe reality what it really is
is they got a comment on a post that
bugged them okay great it's embarrassing
to even have to say that but when you
say it then you admit it and all of a
sudden you put it in the light and the
shame kind of starts to evaporate
because then you can name it and be like
is this comment bigger than my future
one of the things that has helped me was
saying like what's true about this and
the next one is like what if we confront
it and say like what if they're right
and yeah I'm still gonna do it anyways